[Musik]
ich trainiere schon mal für football wm
und damit herzlich willkommen meine
damen und herren hier heute zu einem
neuen video von eurem lieblings youtuber
mit dem fettesten pickel auf der stirn
job freuen dass es einfach blauer himmel
draußen die sonne scheint das sind 27
grad gerade können und ich nehme hier
für euch darin ein video also freundlich
wird sagen allein dafür könnt ihr
einfach schon mal 14 leichter lassen das
ist mir auf jeden fall mega chillig
geredes bereits im titel eingeblendet
meine sehr verehrten lucio ich habe
schon einige male hochgeladen jeder
youtube hat das irgendwie schon mal
gebracht und zwar machen die heute eine
trailer zu la challenge dass keine
ahnung wer das ist reiner tor mit luca
also sie macht ganz normal sport bleibt
bestehen
standard so mache ich auch immer sport
see als solche szenen sind eigentlich
immer dabei
das schon
ausgetanzt
kleines kind wahrscheinlich fliegt
gleich auch ja genauso wie auch auf die
fresse ist finde ich einfach nur traurig
hier ist ein typ er macht einen saal
wieso lacht man über so was ich meine
schaut ihn euch an der nimmt anlauf und
fliegt ball auch keine rückt näher doch
safe dabei sich sein genick brechen
können
da
scheiße ich einfach in die hose aber da
lach ich doch nicht nächstes mal mache
ich eine trailer zu scheißen yahoo
challenge hier irgend so ein typ auf
einer bühne erwarten
ich finds nur ein bisschen zurück ich
finde es wieder dann einfach wieder
aufstieg wie du leicht wenn nichts was
sie dort jetzt ein vater mit seinen
kindern im park und des barock oder nein
das ist nicht wirklich passiert hat das
kind das hat der arme mädchen filmt sich
bei einem wahrscheinlich vorwärtssalto
oder nein sie nimmt jetzt erst den an
schwung und die arme nach unten vor wo
mein gott das ist ein bisschen weit
rechts
ist dann noch ein oder so darüber lache
ich doch nicht also bisher musste
eigentlich noch keiner so richtig lachen
jetzt fällt sie ja wahrscheinlich runter
oder was neo private sich selbst jetzt
da drauf
[Musik]
verbesserungen an der stelle ein kleines
kind tanzt im hintergrund ist ein hund
das gros der hund ich liebe hunde hier
ist eine reithalle
sie zeigt gerade wo die pferde herleiten
sollen im hintergrund ein pferd springt
darüber und das pferd springt weiter
darüber und nein nein fall nicht runter
also hintergrund läuft ein huhn rum das
ist für mich jetzt schon das absolute
highlight das mädel springt allerdings
um auf diesen teil was ich da irgendwie
so komisch dass das kenne ich nur noch
von happy meals kann ich die teile
einmal schauen was die da jetzt was
alter schaut euch das an wie unbeholfen
die keine chance noch mal an ich komme
dass die ganze zeit anschauen kommen
nochmal wie unbeholfen kann ein mensch
sein der wie ein kleines kino was sich
einfach ja okay mit ihm allerdings
geschlagen hat hier ist ein typ auf
einem longbottom
freunde ich zeig euch nochmal
[Applaus]
ist ein longboard ein skateboard glaube
ich maximal kann man nicht so gut mit
tricks machen da sind leute auf einem
schlitten rodelberg und er haut einfach
die kamerafrau um das safe wenn ihre
haare irgendwie anders ist immer mehr so
dass es immer jakob die haare fang an zu
brennen die eltern machen schnell sauber
alles gut die hasen ein bisschen
angebrannt ist ein typ der bdi
was war die mission von dem typen der in
den pool springen wollte also ich meine
er dann den pool gesprungen hier sind
leute die karate machen oder judo oder
ich weiß nicht genau was es ist die
kämpfe jetzt hier zusammen er alter er
hat ihn voll in die fresse getreten
glaube ich okay dafür richtig
schmerzhaft aus aber hier so wieder
leute auf dem berg ich glaube das sind
die gleichen und sie hat jetzt die
kamerafrau um das ist genau das gleiche
video noch sondern perspektive gewesen
hier ist eine frau oder ein mädchen auf
einer rutsche die dafür definitiv
das ganze sollte eigentlich mehr eine
trainer to face pollen challenge sein
hier sind zwei kinder in einem
wohnzimmer und die spielen sowie glaube
ich und müssen irgendwas machen oder
tanzen
wartet alter kummer sieht so richtig
motiviert und wird einfach umgekippt
das war ich wenn ich in der klausur
gegangen bin ein kleines mädchen auf
ihrem fahrrad eine große frau auf ihrem
fahrrad und die beiden da ist ein typ
der will irgendwie lustig sein und dahin
schlittern und jetzt kommt's erste mal
dass ich wirklich lachen musste hier der
typ spieler die rein sie steht da die
rein und das bin ich
das war wirklich leider komplett ich ein
kleines mädchen muss irgendwie
inhalieren oder ein kleiner junge und
haut sich das ding dabei komplett ins
auge hier ist ein anderes kleines
mädchen die auf einem stuhl runter fällt
hier sind zwei kinder auf einem
spielplatz wieder zusammenspielen alter
das ist schon nicht gut aus mein gott
die knallt voller herauf und jetzt lacht
die noch
schaut euch
ich bin noch ein bisschen weiter zurück
schaut euch das jetzt ja da
die hat sich einfach auch komplett das
genick brechen können keinen spaß
freunde seid vorsichtig bei sowas wenn
ihr irgendwie auf einem spielplatz zeit
oder so dass ihr wirklich auf euch auf
passt überall lauern gefahren da kann
auf einmal in dem organ also aus der
wand kommen die haben ja ein kleines
kind mit dem fussball sie wird
wahrscheinlich wieder die kamera
abschließen oder sich maulen und über
den fußball her laufen also sie nimmt
schon gehörig viel anlauf jetzt geht's
los und bam ja sie wird über den ball
herlaufen war klar als nächstes haben
wir hier ein kind ich glaube das ist
eine promotion aufnahme oh mein gott sah
dass an der villa den ball schlagen
schlägt aber den hund tut mir leid er
wollte doch nur mit dem ball spielen die
ist eine junge auf einer rutsche ich
weiß nich tätigen dieser stimmung war
das ist nicht nur nicht richtig sondern
fällt ihm noch die chance auf dem kopf
meinte schaut euch runter und erste hin
und dann kriegt richtig stumpf noch die
rutsche auf kopf aber gut wir haben hier
vorne stühle und irgend jemand der
einfach hin fällt keine ahnung auch mal
über so was machen soll
ich weiß nicht ob mein humor einfach so
dumm ist aber es schaut euch das an was
im moment
was im moment schaut es soweit ich weiß
wenn ich sage ich habe mich dabei gar
nicht an guten humor kriegt man einfach
schon wenn man einfach wäre einfach ein
kleines kind irgendwo gegen das in dem
sound waren aber gut wir machen weiter
wir haben ein kleines mädchen
die world
hat der vater die weggekickt naja gut
jede familie kann er machen was wir
wollen
da ist ein typ der witzig sein genital
bereich irgendwo weh tue ja genau es
bleibt aber hängen kommt ja sehr schön
toll gemacht jetzt freut er sich
hier haben wir ein mädchen was darum
tanz die anderen nicht der stein bricht
ab
er ist auch einfach nur weg
geschäftsbereich passiert hier ist ein
mädel auf einem schwimmreifen
weggeschleudert
dann haben wir als nächstes einen skater
der hochs kälte wieder runter dabei sich
übels mault warum verkauft man sich so
ein motorrad so klein ist das macht
einfach keinen spaß und keinen sinn der
läuft kleine süßes mädchen durch die
küche und
bäume
für mich gibt man noch eine trailershow
land waren einfach nur mit kindern die
wirklich irgendwo glaubt ihr macht
jemand einen handstand gerade an einer
wand und feld war was ich dachte der
fällt hin aber stattdessen gibt einfach
seine wohnung kaputt etwas für das ich
haben hat mich zum lachen bringen an der
stelle wird das heutige video sei
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn euch diese trainers olaf
stelle gefallen hat und ich denke herr
luca macht so was eventuell mal öfter
dazu auf solche videos reagiert dann
erst mal leichter und bei 70.000 likes
es ist eine enorm krass große summe dann
mal werde ich das dann vielleicht mal
wieder hochladen nun meine damen und
herren will ich an der stelle wirklich
einfach nur noch sagen